well several tech CEOs responded to the
YouTube shooting by demanding that
regular people be deprived of their
right to carry firearms that would
include twitter CEO Jack Dorsey tweeted
this quote we can't keep being reactive
to this and thinking and praying it
won't happen again at our schools jobs
our community spots it is beyond time to
evolve our policies he didn't specify
which ones but you know what he was
talking about he cares much more than
you do
Dorsey then endorsed demands issued by
the March for our lives those would
include again not specific banning
high-capacity magazines confiscating all
weapons designated as assault weapons
now what's interesting about all this is
that in 2015 twitter the company he runs
spent more than sixty eight thousand
dollars providing yes personal security
to Jack Dorsey were those guards unarmed
right no they weren't
Joel Payne is former director of
african-american advertising for Hillary
Clinton's 2016 campaign adjoint system a
great to see Joel I appreciate your
coming on so it's hard to read this as
anything else but an effort by the
people in charge to bring more power to
themselves which is what people in
charge do kind of instinctively we get
the guns you don't shut up and obey why
is that not what's happening right now
Tucker I don't I don't really think
that's the right way to look at this
issue and I really enjoyed listening to
your conversation with your colleague a
little bit earlier I'm interested to
hear that you guys think that it's funny
that someone on TV and this environment
thought that a soda can opening was a
gunshot you thought that was funny I
think it's funny but that studio didn't
have gunshots it had a soda opening and
my point is that if you're going to
advocate for positions you have a moral
obligation to learn something about the
topic and most people who are doing that
haven't bothered to learn and that's the
problem I'm not in any way denigrating
the fear people feel in the face of
gunfire I'm making fun of people
mistaking a mountain Dew can for gunfire
but look the point is ordinary people
are afraid you're absolutely right I
think we agree on that so why would the
people in charge who are protected by
armed security demand that no one else
be allowed to protect him
if you see what I mean well I have some
frustration towards what I heard from
the Twitter CEO today before a different
reason I don't like this this trend that
we have of waiting for gun violence to
come to your backyard before you get
woke about it I mean just because it
happened at a tech company yesterday is
you got this letter with all these tech
CEOs who decided to sign on listen I was
touched recently by gun violence I had a
very close friend that was impacted by
what happened at the Veterans Home in
California but guess what I felt
strongly about gun violence and about
you know all of the the concerns around
that before that it didn't take that
issue to to make to pique my interest by
the way I think it's very interesting
Tucker a lot of the people who watch
this show and a lot of people who watch
this network feel the same way I do if
you look at the poll I feel yeah let's
just be let's be honest and one of the
sort of pieces of political rhetoric
that drives me the craziest is the idea
that only a select few care about gun
violence I think most people most normal
people are horrified by shootings I know
I am so the question is not do you feel
deeply better are you upset of course
you're upset
the question is what's the most
effective response what's the wise thing
to do that's where the debate is it's
not over who cares and who doesn't
everybody cares I mean come on now so
yeah don't turn that question back to
you and say well what should we do
yeah I mean the I think well give you a
perfect example so with the parklands
shooting we have a well-documented
string of failures by people whose job
it was to protect the kids in that
school and they didn't there were four
armed cops outside four who heard the
gunfire and didn't go in I never heard
their names mentioned at the March for
our lives I doubt you know their names I
never heard anybody mentioned that we
hired people to protect those kids 17
were murdered because they didn't act
but it's the NRA is false
that's insane that's just pure politics
you're not thinking it seriously if you
reach that conclusion I would say yeah
sorry I didn't mean to interrupt you
there there were a lot of people who
failed those children that day some of
them were the people who didn't run into
those buildings but a number of them
were people who were in the State House
in Tallahassee and who were in Capitol
Hill in Washington DC those people also
failed
you're defending the people in power as
almost everyone on the left does the
people in power are blameless they
didn't do anything wrong it's you out
there who've committed no crime
whatsoever that the guns in my closet if
I had them would be no threat to anybody
but I have to disarm but the cops whose
job it was to protect the kids they're
cool
we can't play in that man someday I just
I didn't say that actually agreed with
you I said they share some blame I said
that to blame didn't in with them though
it also it also extended to the people
who were in Tallahassee at their
Statehouse and in Capitol Hill and it
state houses all across the country
um failed to act so what should they
have to watch I mean I I you know I take
you seriously it's why I wanted to talk
to you tonight so just in the minute and
a half we have left just give me a
discrete step a specific step that they
could have taken to prevent the parkland
shooting for example well let's let's
look at a couple things why why isn't
the president acted on bump stocks that
I thought he was hot to trot on that
here's the problem though Tucker your
your your answer here is well it would
stop this specific culture okay you're
blaming this State House in Tallahassee
for our culture fair culture to gun
violence gun violence is something we
can't do anything about when we know we
can I feel it is something we can do
something about and when armed guards
neglect their duty to protect children I
think we should hold them accountable
you instead shifted the blame from the
people who actually had power to people
whose other positions you don't like in
the State House Republicans and I ask
then trying to be rational what should
they have done and you said Trump should
ban bump stocks which I was gonna say a
little bit more the president can act on
this by the way the NRA they could be
partners here right the NRA is running
scared the reason why you see them
turning John Paul Stevens and a bunch of
17 year old into boogeyman is because
they know public cinnamon is at an
all-time low for what they fight for
which is the right for gun manufacturers
they make here
Ewing rhetoric and bumper stickers I
want actual solutions because you know
I'd like you I care I wanted to know
what the new law is that would have
prevented parkland there are a lot of
shootings a lot of different causes I
asked for one specific answer to that
one and I got bum stalks and John Paul's
give you this is give me more I can give
you more about we can restrict access to
people who are mentally ill to have done
can stop the terrorists from purchasing
guns we could have done that Congress
wouldn't do that
you got to me's legislation legislation
so many people have tried to act on this
but the intransigence in Washington why
if you go buy a gun it screens people
who are mentally ill the authorities the
actual authorities failed to screen this
kid despite the fact everyone knew he
was mentally ill they didn't do anything
Americans and the majority of
Republicans actually disagree with you
and the polling reflects that well I
don't know what to say those are the
facts Joel thank you thank you thank you
I appreciate it